all right guys big day around here i'm
about to interview
president donald j trump we are doing a
sit down
although it's a slightly different sit
down because he is doing it
via the phone the the classic style of
interviewing
uh from an undisclosed location but
before we start i want to say one thing
which is that his team made it very
clear
i can ask him absolutely anything
nothing is off the record
nothing is to be hidden or not to be
asked
and will i get booted off youtube for
this i suppose
we will find out so here we go my
interview with president donald j
trump all right president donald trump
welcome to the reuben report
well thank you very much david great
great to be with you
uh so president what are the chances
that i don't get kicked off
twitter and youtube and facebook just
for talking to you
oh i think you have about a ten percent
chance a good solid ten percent
ten percent getting kicked off for ten
percent no no ten percent staying on
actually uh you know it's uh it's crazy
this is a crazy world and uh let's see
what all happens i think they're over
playing their hand but we'll find out
about that dave
yeah so do you miss twitter that seems
to be the big question that everyone
wants to know that was your thing do you
miss it at all
so something happened that's i think
you've seen and that's very interesting
i do press releases like i used to you
know the circle goes round and round
right
i do press releases and it seems that a
lot of people are waiting
for those press releases and if you look
at the of all places the new york times
did a story a week ago
about the circulation of what i'm saying
is essentially as big
it's very big and the word is getting
out i did a couple of them today
i like because i'm not confined as to uh
number of characters but you know the
number of characters you don't want to
keep it too long anyway okay that's one
thing we all learned maybe from that
no i i think uh i think we're doing very
well with that being said i'll be on
social media in the not too distant
future we're looking at a lot of options
we had
hundreds of millions of people you know
if you look at we had 91
on one site we had 10 and another we had
36 on another we had potus
we have a lot of people and a lot of
people on facebook
and i i hear it's become very boring to
be honest that i hear in particular
twitter has become very very boring
and a lot of conservative voices have
gotten off some have been thrown out and
a lot of them have gotten off
and i hear twitter is not doing well and
it's lost his voice
and when i started there like 11 or 12
years ago
it was not a success i mean it was not a
i don't know it was going to make it but
it was not a success it became
very successful and i think you're going
to see a lot of people are going to be
finding other
other there's a lot of platforms out
there that's what we're looking at
getting the right platform a perfect
platform and i think uh
you'll see something fairly soon yeah
that's great to hear and as
you may know i've been talking to to
some of your guys about locals.com which
is the tech company i started so we
shall see
good uh so you know i've told my
audience many times that one of the
reasons that i
uh did i didn't support you in 2016 but
then i did in 2020
was that i started going back and
watching old videos of you
on oprah and on david letterman and on
phil
donahue and i realized that you were
basically
saying the exact same things 30 years
ago
that you're saying now and what that
made me
wonder was sort of did you always you
know they would always ask you oprah
would say oh you should run for
president or donahue would say it but
did you always feel that somebody else
was going to do it and then you just got
pinned into doing it because you didn't
seem to really want to do it
actually you kind of wanted somebody
else to do it from the way
it's a great nobody's ever asked me the
question that way and it's very
interesting
yeah i assumed that somebody else would
do it because people cannot be that
stupid
to be taken advantage of by china
and in particular at that time if you go
back 20 or 30 years it was japan was
really doing a number on i said
it's all the same and frankly it hasn't
changed because whether it's china japan
or many others i mean it's
they're all taking but china obviously
right now is
the head of the pack and i always felt
that somebody else said nobody's ever
asked it this way
i've always felt that somebody else
would do it
and they didn't and it went for a long
time you know those interviews
and one thing you have to say dave if
nothing else i was consistent
i mean it was i've seen it too where
i've seen a recently a replay of some of
the statements and
they're almost identical to what i say
now and i was right
i was right we have now 30 trillion in
debt
we have a country that is just that's
just ridiculous what's going on in so
many ways i talk about the border even
then people coming in
and you know the wrong people coming in
in many cases
and you see what's happening with the
prisons are being emptied out in other
countries and they're coming into our
country
and i i was uh yeah very consistent
it's very interesting yeah when did you
realize that you were gonna fully
have to say what you thought because
when i started going to
some of your rallies and i'm here in
crazy los angeles
i was going to the trump rallies in
beverly hills and it was
a joy fest like it was it was truly
unbelievable i couldn't believe it and
the main thing people would
say to me when they would come they'd
say dave you know i'm just sick of being
called a racist and a homophobe and a
bigot and everything else
and i met these people these were the
nicest joyest happiest decent americans
ever but when did you realize that you
were just going to have to sort of walk
through that fire and and take those
those labels so a lot of people think i
was going to run like for a long time
you know they were asking me that
question
30 years ago as you would say and oprah
was and donahue was and they were all
doing it and
and i'd give the answer that i doubt it
because believe it or not dave i'm a
very honest person
and you know i'm not sure that you can
be honest and be in politics okay and
i never really thought i was gonna do it
a lot of people thought i was going to
do it eight years ago 12 years ago
i think probably it really hit me when
i turned down a big extension on the
apprentice you know the show was a very
big success i did it
for 14 seasons can you believe it
and then schwarzenegger i missed joan
rivers i missed joan rivers man she was
she was the best oh yeah she wanted to
come on and they all wanted to come on i
watch erin burnett
you know now but she would beg me to go
down the show she
she was on three or four times she would
virtually beg me
to be on the apprentice and now i watch
her hit from you know all sides on
msdnc i don't watch her very much but i
see she's on there and i assume she says
nothing but bad but she would beg to be
on as as did
others as did many others but the show
was a great success
and they wanted to extend it a lot
like at the highest level they came over
to my office
and i said no i gotta i have to do this
i have to run for president and they
thought i was kidding
they didn't want to hear it they wanted
to extend the show they ended up getting
arnold schwarzenegger who failed badly
as you know it was often
like a matter of minutes and they also
during the time they get martha stewart
and she failed
but we had a great success and it was
for many years and
i said no and you know when you turn
down a primetime show long-term
extension
it's a lot of money no matter how rich
you are but it's a lot of money
and a lot of prestige and i turned them
down the top executives
of nbc came over and they wanted to make
a deal and i turned them down and i
guess so
that was really when i thought i was
going to do it and then of course
the famous uh write down the escalator
and that was it
if that was it once i wrote down the
escalator with our great
first lady that uh that turned out to be
it
when did you realize how connected the
sort of mainstream media was to the
swamp you know you were talking about
draining the swamp and obviously the
media was going after you
and you started punching back and
republicans or conservatives or people
on the right usually don't
punch back did yeah did you realize it
was it by the time you were president
that you fully realized or it was really
was it that first debate no i thought it
was bad
frankly but i never knew it was this bad
and now it's worse than ever before it's
now it's so ridiculous i mean
you see uh where uh biden gets up and
says things that nobody can believe or
doesn't say things and they say
could that be fdr fdr great speaker
and uh you know no now it's it's out of
control but
uh i've always known that they were
shaky but i used to get great press
you know before i ran for i guess that's
probably one of the reasons i won
before i ran for president i got a lot
of great press
i was getting i was the king i was
getting
pressed like nobody and uh you know i
did fine but i
also understood uh where and
how they were functioning as much as you
can nobody understands the press fully
to be honest with you i don't care
how well you do with it but once i
announced and when i made the first
speech in trump tower once i get down
from the escalator i will tell you
uh i would say the press turned
radically different
and now they become very corrupt i mean
they're really corrupt it's uh
it's a terrible thing to watch we don't
have freedom of the press anymore we
don't have free press or fair press
and we have a very very corrupt press
and and you don't even have to get into
the argument although you say plenty
you have strong opinions on it but we
have a very very corrupt
media yeah no they're they're long gone
they're activists not journalists
they're gonzo they're they're guns uh
we're doing a big one in uh
ohio on saturday night and people are
already lined up and
you know there's just been a great
connection to the people i've had a
great connection to the people
and it's amazing because when you get
virtually a hundred percent
bad press and fox is a whole different
ballgame from what it was too by the way
but when you get a hundred percent
anti-press it's just
uh look you have some really great great
people who should have gotten the
pulitzers you have people that called
russia russia russia exactly right
they don't get the pulitzers they give
pulitzer prizes to people that were
totally wrong
totally wrong it's a disgrace but when
you have that and it's amazing
that even in the last election i get far
more votes in the last election
and did far better than i did in the
first election in 2016.
and it's amazing that you can have the
press
so against you big tech against you and
you end up getting 75 million votes
which is the highest
anybody's ever gotten as a sitting
president it's
it's pretty amazing but what it shows
you is that
the people of our country get it they
really get it it's pretty amazing
yeah are you must be incredibly psyched
to get back out there with the people
and i know you're doing some shows with
bill o'reilly and the rallies are going
to start up right i mean to me it's just
that
people just want to be proud of america
again i can't wait until they start up
rallies whether you're there or not just
to get
people out there and holding flags and
being proud to be americans again
well we're doing a big one in florida i
guess it's july 3rd and we're doing a
big one in ohio on saturday night and
we're we're going to start doing it
just to give people some pride again
it's not you know it's early
but it's not really early because
[Laughter]
you know they want to know they want to
have a voice out there and you don't get
it from the media they don't give you a
fair voice
so you have to do it a little bit
differently and you know in the one case
sending out those press releases they
get onto twitter and they get onto
facebook and they get on to everything i
mean it's uh
it's been that's been amazing but the
voice that really gets out of
is the voice at the rallies because they
cover the rallies you know they cover
the rallies because of ratings
the one thing ratings are most important
okay
if you get great ratings they're going
to cover you no matter what you say and
we get a lot of coverage and i think
it's very important
and that's what the people want because
they love the country
they hate open borders they hate you
know
sanctuary cities protect people that are
criminals in many cases i mean sanctuary
cities
they hate defund the police think of the
policies these people have defund the
police sanctuary cities
open borders let anybody come into our
country criminal or not
and it's supposed to be all wonderful
and now cancel culture
and all of the other things you're
seeing on the school boards right
and they're supposed to win i don't i
don't believe they can win with that
and
because those are not 50 issues uh
let's uh as an example we talked about
energy
right during the debates during the
campaign
and we're energy independent but we're
not any longer now we're going to have
to start buying from
the middle east and russia and all these
other places we're energy independent
now we're not because they've canceled a
lot of deals canceled the pipeline how
about
canceling the pipeline but letting
russia have its pipeline to europe and
germany
and it's just it's i don't believe that
those policies are anywhere near
50 but i think
yeah i think by ten percent that you
predicted about staying on youtube may
have just dropped i think
let me reduce it yeah that's all right
that's right
let me just ask you a couple other
things because i want to be respectful
of your time were you ever
really were you ever really worried
about impeachment because i
saw you i don't know if you remember
this but we we actually met briefly at
mar-a-lago
uh back in december of uh i guess it was
2018
and i had seen you speak that afternoon
at a turning point event and it was in
the midst of the impeachment thing
dan crenshaw went on stage with you and
brought out his piece of paper that
showed you know he didn't vote for it
and
uh but but everybody was saying the
walls are closing in he's freaking out
and i saw you that night you had no tie
on you were relaxed you were laughing
like were you ever really really worried
or even on the second time around
well they had no proof either time they
had no proof
and frankly you know i have a lot of
good relationships in congress in the
senate
and in the house and i will say this
richard nixon did not
now he also had you know 300 tapes right
that didn't help him
the tapes weren't exactly positive they
were
a total disaster but i have a lot of
great friends in congress
jim jordan and so many others banks and
uh debbie lesko i i just have so many
great friends and i felt in the same way
in
the senate i have a lot of great friends
in the senate and i didn't feel that
assuming i was innocent
i didn't feel that they would sell me
down the river
and i you know i felt very confident and
you know you'd see
a cnn where they say he's walking the
white house he's walking in his room
and i'd be in the oval office right
that'd be you know not even
i'll never forget i was with a group of
people very very big
business people from another country
having to do with bringing business to
this country
but i'll never forget a dave where the
television was on and cnn was saying i
was
up in my bedroom storming the bed and
i'm in the oval office with these
business people trying to get them to
invest in america
and they said wow that's really
dishonest i said that's what i've been
saying
no there's tremendous dishonesty dave
tremendous
all right last question for you for now
and then i hope we get to do this in
person at some point
i never i've literally never done this
in any interview i never asked the
audience to ask
a question but i thought let's try this
with president trump and there were many
versions of this
question which basically is that pretty
much everybody doesn't think biden is in
charge nobody really thinks he's running
the show
so the question is something to the
effect of who do you think is
really running this thing is this the
obama machine is this the clinton
machine is this
something else what do you really think
is happening right now
i think it's a group of people and a lot
of people say susan rice and obama and a
lot of people say
perhaps clinton to a lesser extent
although she never got along with biden
and she's very very angry because she
said why didn't you do that for her you
know she was saying
because it's it was far easier because
that race was far closer
than the race we just had the 2020 race
and uh but you have people that
it's it's a group of people i don't
think it's biden
frankly and i you know in many ways wish
it were because that's the way it's
supposed to be
but i don't believe it is and maybe uh
harris
to an extent although i don't think
she's distinguishing herself with her
her border trips and now all of a sudden
i said as soon as i announced i'm going
to the border
i actually made a minor bet i said watch
what happened she's going to announce
and right after i announced as you know
she announced that she's going down i
guess she's going
tomorrow or something but she would have
never gone to the border
and i'm going next week so uh i think
it's just a group of people
i mean think of it when he signed those
17
declarations special orders presidential
orders
he signed them and he didn't really seem
to know what the hell he was signing
no he didn't when you think of them they
were all sitting there waiting to be
signed
and they were radical they were radical
they were bernie sanders would have
never asked for most of the things that
he's signing this is far worse than
bernie sanders
ever imagined and it's pretty amazing so
a lot of people ask that group who is it
it's really i think it's a group
of people and you know the same names
but it's a group of people
and they get together and this is what
they want to do and they're destroying
our country
really destroying our country last
question then i promise i'll let you go
what does president trump do for fun
you're about to hit the weekend it's the
summer's start and what are you doing
for fun these days besides golfing i
know you're golfing
well i do i i try and get to play golf
because it keeps me
a little bit busy and a little bit of
exercise and it's good and
and i exercise a little bit but what i
really do is work i mean i work i'm
running a business
now and very importantly i'm very much
involved in the endorsements you know
our endorsements have meant so much if i
endorse somebody they win
almost almost a hundred percent of the
time and
a lot of senators and congressmen and
many others we just won in north
carolina head of the party
and we won in georgia ahead of the party
and we won in texas as you know and
louisiana congress and and you know just
the endorsements i think it's 228 and 2
over the last fairly short period of
time 200 think of that 228 and 2.
so they're coming from me at ohio we
have a good guy
in ohio running two good guys running
for congress and
we have a lot of good people running so
i've done i've done a lot of that we're
having a lot of meetings with people
that want the endorsement we're trying
to get people that you would like in
there dave
i'm glad to hear well mr president i
really appreciate you taking the time
and enjoy the weekend and i hope we can
connect again
we will and thank you very much you've
done a great job thanks steve
thanks take care if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell